blog numero 22 è che l'ultimo periodo di
che l'ultimo ieri basta poi sul discorso
ci picchiano tv gli abbonati al social
viola che salutiamo e l'ultimo log
queste ragazze di farci fare delle
vendite
no non è vero il penultimo blog e se
come voglio festeggiare questa giornata
nera salsiccia e voglia di salsiccia di
circolazione con la salsiccia un
tranquillo a breve torneremo essere una
famiglia normale
per me di una casa troppo piccola per
noi ma non sa quale veramente nessuno ci
lascerà del cibo in giro e quindi voi
smetterete nutrirvi di spazzatura ti
piace come idea ma che fuori dalla
camera preso tutto a suo padre ma questo
è un pigro ha preso fuoco da te è vero
non è sincero e umile generoso ma lo sai
che l'altro giorno è venuto a dormire da
me è una [ __ ] farmi mangiare farmi
mangiare cammino targa forza ed il
copyright ma la canzone michela che ci
ha mandato tutta questa roba da mangiare
grave da meritare cannata ringrazio voi
che mi avete lasciato il culo scusate ma
senti che cos'è r
ma mite questo pure con un goccio dalla
banca
ciao ciao la tendina assaggiato
valentina è una cacata di quelle proprio
ma in realtà insieme attivato
suggerimenti che sono stati andrea e
alessio alberto taglio al corso bruno
bernabeu
barabba carlo charlie anche ci sta
ciro tutti questi nell'ultima settimana
è stata rinchiusa dire che l'unica eto'o
dalla prima gara
vediamo perché non è vero noi non
prendiamo in giro le persone elette le
righe
grazie a dreamer queste panoramiche
quanto 2007 per un tiro di momi la
padella riprendermi micidiale fatto male
che te ne pare del suo solamente palermo
ottimo marco rossi nozomi ricordi enrico
ekman anno a buccia infatti enrico
peggio a madrid a una semplice azione
mettere a parte nella 4 e poi assaggi
martin siete voi minutaggio assaggiate
weil assaggio anche usiamo parla
approfonditamente su indagini così per
favore chiede team minutaggio di
mappaggio io l'ho con disco direttamente
nera camera quindi praticamente permetta
a 30 secondi sul poca co2 pronta a
maggio cioè che profumo a quella sul
pane carasau filetto di olio è quella
che anche super bravi che l'ha fatta la
pinerolo mantecata io no grazie con
teheran davanti all epoca pensate voi
fate i piatti ordinati per i dati perché
sono fatti posso fare tutto gratis
avvenuto nel black adesso chi mangia
prima voti sei veramente superato per
fruire già buonissima parte col cuore
ne mancano due di blogger e poi
finalmente spogliamento tutte queste
bugie e dire la mia verità di luca mia
madre ha sommato mag penso che tu sei la
mia quella cosa li facciamo un cinema le
prende il bicchiere
[Musica]
no
ha proceduto detto che dovevo fare
queste cose e non ti ho detto niente
ma cosa miglior personaggio perdonavano
tutti essere lei che adesso dobbiamo
preoccupare si guarda allo stato
allora ti mettiamo la maschera se
quest'acqua è appena vi diciamo via vai
di tir e il cappuccio di reni la
maschera e ti guardi allo specchio
il cappuccio non esco e può dire poi ti
guardi allo specchio non guardare noi
guarda sempre te come se noi non ci
fossimo e non vado vado ha detto che poi
nonna attenta al dall'ara ma prima per
me ma guarda dove vuoi passare non
voglio cercare the tesoro
ci abbracciamo che non si sa mai che non
si sa quanto sei bella donna ma tu
quando si arriva come quando sara penzo
spettante fa lo gnorri pensano fa a
tutti i sei venuta gianluigi che provo a
cucinare semi mai mollato questo che è
bravissimo che ha detto a mangiare io lo
aspetto con ansia e anch'io non ti
aspetto con ansia questo natale siamo io
te gabriele ci divertiamo a tombola
tutto facciamo alla pazza gioia nove
ragazzi presenti con questo pensiero
dito può essere mai che non glielo punti
non ha mai fatto benissimo
amore a doppiare ai scavato di cosa ieri
ho detto no ma vieni ti porto in un
posto che dobbiamo un attimo ti faccio
perché dove vivono i ragazzi lo siamo
noi
dati che bello vado a trovare i ragazzi
caro gabriele quanto è stato guardo
[Risate]
brava nonna casi però mai rifilato i
peggiori almeno gianluigi de vita torna
ti piace di più questo bagno
ecco i pullman questo qua mi piace
questo è il bagno che tu mi fai quando
questo e pullman nome di un autobus è
vero ma che sta facendo al sabato al
pullman
ecco mi rendo come lenti rosa ricordo
quando ero piccola quanti anni avevo
piccoli secondo andiamo a letto insieme
contro che li leggevo sempre le favole
ha cominciato a leggere però è come se
mi stavo per venire il sonno e quella
vocina
ma come credo che va a 4 anni rompevo le
scatole aziende chiama gabriele nonna ti
chiama gabriele sentite mirate cappotto
pronti disorienta nonna superare l'inter
artista o non nella mente dell'artista
guardi mi parla senza mani dai nostri
ora gabriele ti porto a casa ok va bene
fisicamente l'auto placido con l'autore
scena con la macchina mi davo bene ai
miei denti
ecco da chi non ha preso una breve ma
scusate tentano le macchine del di
cristo insegnò maiava duce nota in
quanto aprirci gianluigi sta preparando
e cosa preferisci gianluigi donna ed
andiamo e torniamo per sei solo piacere
il nostro non può lasciare qui non ti
interessa
hai detto che puoi andare via non appena
alla quarta domanda di una portata in
testa
vai pure via ciao no valentina non è
necessario che la salute come può stare
che concorrono alcuni di questi
bastoncino
questo è il mio gol l'americano l'africa
c'è di peggio gori sono felice avevi
viso non che mi avete fatto un po di
spirito un pochettino
grazie grazie
[Risate]
come tema rischio andare in macchina con
lui
[Musica]
ciao ciao nonna presta ci vediamo
benissimo non ti sei divertita tanto
visto che sono caduto si è terribile ma
come fai a fare queste cose
terribile 90 va beh non mi sono
spaventata perdiamo tutti insieme
certo perché non te ne frega niente male
io ti chiamo la mia
ecco perché non ti sei sparita marta
guarda e si sta portando in un'altra
dimensione
indispettito tutta la forza dei 90 anni
la donna c'è la forza di palos
per questo spesso ti ritrovi in una casa
antica con i portoni enormi di quegli
antichi dovrei riuscire a tirare il
portone attirare proprio potere e
potenza disumana la potenza disumana
mi prendo il secondo ragazzo mi prendo
un secondo dicevo partito aias per fare
un video al volo cioè un segmento in
realtà di video al volo per parlare in
un argomento e mi è stato chiesto nelle
ultime ore tantissimo che è quello
legato ad economia a rispondere commenti
che gli sono stati lasciati ci sono
stati lasciati sotto il video nel quale
andiamo nel locale degli amici di scuola
di mio fratello commenti che in parte
hanno criticato delle iscrizioni
eravamo io ei ragazzi del volo nel
locale
allora io staro pelose
sarà bellissimo e perché è stato il
gabriele vorrebbe fare un video più
lungo quindi non mi va di scavalcarlo in
questo si tengono semplicemente a dire
ci sono dei commenti che secondo me sono
sacrofano guidate al fatto che se uno
può mandare un messaggio sbagliato poi
indipendentemente da quella che tutta la
dietrologia dietro perché la tecnologia
che noi conosciamo ma che magari può non
esser letta e quindi una persona porta
il far male può dire a tavola ma quindi
questi questa cosa che noi il casco di
bari in questo qui è una cosa che in cui
credo chiedo scusa per la forma delle
cose perché è importante non tutti sanno
che c'è sempre una densa immediata detto
questo non non mi sento però di conclude
in questo modo il video perché si sono
un paio di cose che vorrei dire e quando
si tratta di e le scuse che ho sempre
fatto il 3d master esclusa anche quando
mi sono detto ma potevi evitare chiedere
scusa asta bot e devo però per forza
aggiungere un ma ragazzi non serve
urlare per essere ascoltati questo qui è
per una lezione ed una richiesta che
faccio pertanto inter non serve
coordinate per essere ascoltati non
serve improvvisamente passare da al
complimento alla critica cacchina nella
quale i comizi obscene comincia a
parlare di falsità di sinistra fare
anche forme di bodiroga e sgravato è
veramente sgravato una cosa
così e non è secondo me sana e stabile
non è un comportamento stabile ed
equilibrato cioè sentire di dover urlare
in questo modo questa rabbia talmente
semplicemente quello che potrebbe essere
un discorso molto più tranquillo delle
spiegazioni comunque che sono hanno
fatto da attualmente almeno la sono un
po fa paura di me fa paura il fatto che
all'alba diciamo di questo di questo
video quali lo io parlavo venirsi a
cipro subito a termine del mio telefono
forte sono tre studenti sono ma parlerà
di questo parlerà del video ma parlerà
dei commenti ora io ringrazio internet e
che hanno detto ragazzi gli è successo
ieri
datemi tempo vi ringrazio riverso
tantissimo e forse c'è una sola cosa ci
tengo a dire che non vuole essere un
discorso alla sovrana ti prego
compilatelo come tale però ne lumi madre
mi dice cosa devo dire che cosa devo
dire io non permetto a nessuno di
mettermi in bocca dei fondi con tre
concetti o delle delle affermazioni o
ripeto non sono pronto per farle 2000 di
fatto è questo che sia chiaro e magari
pistono su un cazzo per questo a me dire
una cosa controvoglia non va in questo
momento questo segmento in passato del
predetto importante ragazze è
importantissimo e so che ebrei vengono a
parlare è importantissimo specialmente
se internet è dare i giusti messaggi e
calibrati oddio aspetta non perdono
ringrazio sempre quando qualcuno mi fa
notare all occhio questa cosa può essere
prese a male sta attento a questa 70
quest'altro e finale che sono già pace
antoni delle cose alle quali stiamo
attenti io purtroppo non viene in
particolare per quanto io come sand
retroscena
non sono rimasto sconvolto stato colpito
in particolare non l'ho potuto di
io in prima persona perché quel giorno
io in giro per il furto che avevo subito
e quindi non è che sono stato dietro al
montaggio perdonate non esisteva anche
la mia vita privata che un attimo della
spada così sconvolta ha detto ciò chiudo
dicendo
raga non serve urlare le messe ascoltati
si possono dire le stesse identiche cose
un tocco di umanità infilare vi sono il
primo che sbaglia sono il primo che
accordo con lei si chiude la vera parte
troppo e chiede scusa ma poi a domani
con lui un giorno sono incazzato e con
misure della mascherina tra delle cose
le donne vanno dette e mi sento un po
più leggero poi magari verranno
originati contro di mettre en el naaman
voglio dire sono abituato a non dover
per forza piacere a tutti voglio dire
che chi ci sta ci sta assolutamente ci
sono cose che mi pesano di più e altre
nelle quali sono più sereno perché
volevo senza questa è una di quelle case
bacio già ma domani con l'ultimo gradi